hommes femmes enfants ils sont des
milliers à s'être résignés à fuir
souvent à pied la partie nord de la
bande de Gaza qui traverse une crise
humanitaire sans précédent alors que les
combats urbains entre tsal et le Hamas
font rage au cœur de la ville de Gaza
les Tau se resserrent désormais sur les
hôpitaux en effet l'armée israélienne
accuse les combattants du Hamas de s'en
servir comme d'un bouclier humain à des
fins militaires au cœur des inquiétudes
l'hôpital alchifa le plus grand de la
bande de Gaza qui est submergé de
blessés et accueillerait plus de 15000
réfugiés selon le bureau de la
coordination de l'aide humanitaire de
l'ONU depuis quelques jours
l'établissement est assiégé par l'armée
israélienne et totalement privé d'eau et
d'électricité faute de carburant
nécessaire au fonctionnement des
générateurs les patients sont abandonnés
à eux-mêmes les plaes s'infectent elles
grouillent de verre l'hôpital est la
cible de tir direct impossible d'aller
ramasser les cadavres qui pourrissent
dans la cour samedi l'hôpital d'alchifa
avait annoncé que 39 bébés prématurés
étaient encore souscouveus et que les
infirmiers procédaient à des massages
respiratoires à la main pour les
maintenir en vie mais six d'entre eux
seraient déjà décédés et tous les
patients sous ventilation artificielle
risquent le même sort selon Médecins
sans frontières de son côté l'armée
israélienne assure qu'un corridor
humanitaire pour quitter l'hôpital était
toujours en place depuis le début du
conflit près de 200000 Palestiniens
auraient déjà fui le nord du territoire
via des couloirs sécurisés pour regagner
la partie sud de la bande de Gaza selon
l'armée israélienne mais le sort de
nombreux civils dans la zone d'opération
des forces israéliennes inquiète de plus
en plus la communauté international
alors que les bombardements incessants
de l'État hébreu auraient déjà tué plus
de 11000 personnes majoritairement des
civils dont plus de 4600 enfants selon
le Hamas aujourd'hui des civils sont
bombardés des bébés des femmes des
personnes âgées sont bombardées et tuées
on ne peut pas expliquer qu'on veut
combattre le terrorisme en tuant des
innocents nous incitons Israël à arrêter
au cours d'un appel d'Emmanuel Macron
avec le président israélien Isaac Herzog
ce dernier aurait réitéré que l'État
d'Israël et l'armée Contin continuent
d'agir de façon humanitaire en accord
avec la loi internationale rapporte la
[Musique]
présidence